bonsoir blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous alors combien qu'on comprenne
pourquoi le président vénézuélien
propose-t-il ce troc
ben je crois que valeo propose ce proc
parce que d'abord ça lui permettrait de
contourner l'embargo américain sur le
pétrole
cet embargo est assez sévère parce que
ça veut dire que les entreprises
américaines n'ont pas le droit de chez
des prix du pétrole vénézuélien alors
qu'autrefois d'en acheter beaucoup et ça
veut dire aussi que n'importe quel autre
pays ne peut pas acheter ce pétrole
s'ils utilisent des dollars et celui qui
vise le circuit bancaire américain donc
ceci fait un embargo
assez assez complet et puis la deuxième
raison c'est que monsieur maduro a
commandé deux millions deux zones
deux doses par don à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé dans le cadre du
programme multilatéral de vaccination
qui s'adresse au pays
les mois les moins développés ceux qui
n'ont pas de moyens et que
malheureusement il a un conflit
financier avec l'organisation mondiale
de la santé des cotisations non versées
et par conséquent le ms ne lui livre pas
ses vaccins donc il a un problème la
troisième raison c'est sans doute que
sont en grand rival garrido a dit mais
si j'étais au pouvoir ce serait en
mesure de disposer des fonds qui sont
actuellement bloqués aux états unis et
avec ces fonds je pourrais acheter des
vaccins
ça fait trois raisons tu parais retraite
politique en effet pour faire cette
proposition
il a sans doute en tête aussi les le
troc que le venezuela a pratiqué avec
des pays voisins à petite échelle pour
obtenir du café avec l'uruguay y avec le
nicaragua
et puis sans doute il pense aussi à
l'opération beaucoup plus ambitieuse qui
avait été faite par les nations unies
dans les années 90 il s'appelait food
for all pour la population irakienne et
la population ira qu'elles pouvaient
bénéficier de produits alimentaires qui
arrivait de l'extérieur et l'état
irakien payait avec du pétrole mais
c'était quelque chose qui était fondée
sur une résolution du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies qui avait été
adopté par toutes les grandes puissances
y compris les etats-unis la russie et la
chine
donc on est là dans un cadre très
différent et je ne suis pas sûr que la
proposition de monsieur magourou et
beaucoup de succès d'autant plus qu'il
n'a peut être pas beaucoup de pétrole à
exporter alors où on est la crise
sanitaire au venezuela
et bien la crise sanitaire
on a les chiffres officiels finalement
1600 morts ce qui n'est pas beaucoup
compte tenu de la population
beaucoup de gens disent que c'est sans
doute sous-estimé mais ce que tous les
observateurs et tous les vénézuéliens
disent c'est que les hôpitaux débordent
et surtout les hôpitaux sont totalement
sous-équipés pas de matériel est très
souvent pas de produits élémentaires
pas de ça on pour l'hygiène minimum donc
le tout le système sanitaire a été
détruit par la crise économique qui
sévit qui sévit au venezuela avec
actuellement une inflation faramineuses
puisque en un an l'augmentation des prix
a été de 4 mille pour cent
le pnb a chuté des deux tiers en cinq
ans et le 5 millions de vénézuéliens
sont partis un million et demi pour la
colombie d'autres pour l'espagne pour
l'europe
ça fait donc un cinquième de la
population qui est qui a quitté le
venezuela en raison de la crise
humanitaire de la crise sanitaire de la
crise sociale de la crise économique et
la crise politique c'est une
véritablement une crise globale qui fait
d'ailleurs que la richesse principale du
venezuela le pétrole n'est plus vraiment
exploité puisque l'entreprise publique
qui s'occupaient de cette exploitation
a servi de un fonds financier pour le
parti au pouvoir et qu aucun
investissement n'a été fait depuis
plusieurs années dans ce secteur et par
conséquent ce secteur est tout à fait
devenu tout à fait obsolète et doit être
remis à niveau moyennant les
investissements importants c'est
peut-être pour ça que monsieur dame
almagro envisage des privatisations
alors concernant présent les relations
entre les états unis et le venezuela
qu'on sait où le zinfandel janvier me
connaissent mais d'euros appelé joe
biden âge au site tourner la page à ce
que les relations entre les deux pays
peuvent s'améliorer
ben c'est sûrement une bonne idée il
avait très belle relation à l'époque de
donald trump et c'est donald trump qui a
mis toutes ses sanctions sur les
exportations du pétrole vénézuélien
donc en effet une nouvelle
administration américaine peut-être dans
le fond peut-il espérer un nouveau
regard et peut-être peut-il espérer un
rétablissement des relations
diplomatiques puisque trump avait coupé
toutes les relations diplomatiques et
toutes les relations politiques avec le
venezuela
ceci est envisageable
actuellement on n'est pas sûr que
l'administration weiden c'est dans cet
état d'esprit
d'autant plus que monsieur clinton le
secrétaire d'état monsieur blinken le
secrétaire d'état avait déclaré il ya
deux trois mois que il considérait que
monsieur maduro était un dictateur
dangereux et qu' il n'était pas prêt en
effet à négocier avec lui et que blinken
était plutôt sur la ligne il fallait
changer ce gouvernement laly
néoconservatrice en réalité
traditionnelle américaine qui est
reprise par blinken
et peut-être les états unis pourrait-il
faire une tentative en incitant certains
pays latino américains à faire une
médiation
ceci serait probablement la meilleure
solution pour sortir de la difficulté
actuelle et surtout sortir les
vénézuéliens de la crise épouvantable
dans laquelle ils se trouvent sur le
plan humanitaire et sur le plan social
merci claude blanche maison expert en
relations internationales